on n'a pas pas
comme ça se promener dans l'année
on ne peut pas même s'ils ont foulé
heureux
[Musique]
et pourtant sans est réputé bon
j'avoue franchement que segrestan au
soleil
remplaçant au soleil
[Musique]
montrez votre poitrine ça ne vous gêne
pas absolument pas parce que c'est un
jeune mais autres votre avis je pense
pas je suis venu en vacances pour me
faire briser bien sûr et je trouvais ça
tellement agréable de pouvoir se mettre
à l'aise pour vous et torse nu personne
ne vous remarque je trouve ça terrible
et voyez j'ai fait dès le premier jour
je ne pense pas moins est-ce que vous
avez l'impression d'être un des sens pas
du tout ou est-ce qu'il commence la
naissance pour vous toute façon pas
quand on est nu
dont l'un des sens je trouve qu'il est
indécent de se promener dans saint
tropez en maillot de bain en ville et
sur les plages on peut être même une
page et notre soleil
[Musique]
jean pierre beltoise et si votre femme
se promenait en monokini qu'est ce que
vous diriez salut ariz
chacun son opinion mais alors moi pour
le mienne je trouve ça un peu pas
tellement bien est ce que vous le feriez
à non pas moi surtout pas dans les
enfants comme ce matin quand on arrive
et on a vu une personne vraiment tout nu
qui faisait sa gymnastique vraiment
c'est dans les enfants c'est à nous
défendre
et vous madame qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais moi aussi je suis vraiment
content parce que vous savez devant des
enfants de 10 ans et moi je suppose
qu'il ya des pères des mères de familles
qui doivent trouver ça vraiment au jeu
de se mettre dans des détenus comme ça
qu'on est enfant voyez j'ai ma fille moi
qui a 10 ans qui m'a dit maman tu veux
pas te mettre comme ça alors c'est
pourtant naturel non pas un côté naturel
qu'on fasse des plages privées
socialement pour sada corm alors non je
pense que j'aurais quand même
non mais vous savez ici les gens qui
viennent là vous viennent leurs
partisans à quoi s'en tenir au pain
vient ici pour se faire balancer torse
nu et vous savez nous sommes un peu en
famille
ai-je tout ça très bien il n'y a
absolument aucune gêne envoyé au sol
projet vous êtes plagistes à saint
tropez
oui sur votre plage beaucoup de filles
aux seins nus est aussi un écriteau
monokini est interne
il est par décret gelé après il ya pas
longtemps gelé a pris d'ailleurs par la
gendarmerie mais moi je peux pas
m'opposer au fait que les clients
on passe pas toujours les clients les
gens de passage qui regarde les gens qui
passent en ce moment il y en a beaucoup
qui sont qui respectent pas la loi je
crois moi j'y peux pas grand chose je ne
suis qu un plagiste je peux les empêcher
de faire des choses interdites les
choses qui soit contre la loi mais ça
arrive précisément 5 entre la loi se
promener sans soutien gorge
bah oui je les aprilia récemment moi ça
m'avait jamais choqué je me lève est
jamais rendu compte lorsque vous
apercevez un guêpier à l'horizon qu'est
ce que vous faites et bien à ce
moment-là du nous retournons nous nous
mettons sur le sur le ventre en général
ils sont venus notre choix ici lioret et
me l'ont demandé
très gentiment de dire pourra remettre
nikkei
[Musique]
j'ouvre les bras au soleil
walkyrie 4 des femmes dont une belle
poitrine et 420 ça me déplaît pas votre
enfant elles peuvent le laisser de côté
[Musique]